We have our strawberry liquid. I have my alcohol. I'm going to uncap it. I want
you come in close, so you can see what I'm doing. Now, I've got my pink
liquid. I'm going to add about an equal volume
of the alcohol to the glass. And I
want to slowly pour it down the side. Really
carefully, so as not to disturb what's going on.
Now if I do this right, I should have a nice layer of alcohol laying on top of
my strawberry liquid. And I don't know if you can see it clearly yet. But right
there in the liquid. In what we call
the interface. There's some cloudy material showing up. And
so I'm going to take my fork. You put
it inside. And I'm going to swirl. Now if you
come in over top of me here, what you'll notice. If you did this
well, you see what's attached at the bottom of my fork? That's DNA right there.
So I'm going to put it back in, spool it around a little bit more,
and pull it right out, and there you have it. Now, it's time for you to take
a picture, that you can put on Facebook, of you and your DNA.
[MUSIC]